OK, so today we're
going to continue
our discussion of protection.
Remember, we have our
three protection primitives
that we've been talking about,
authentication, authorization
and confidentiality.
Today we're mostly going
to focus on authorization
and confidentiality.
Remember, we have
seen, and we are
going to continue
to rely on this set
of cryptographic primitives.
So the cryptographic
primitives that we talked about
are sign and verify.
And we said that sign accepts
a message and some key.
And verify accepts the
message and some k.
Sign accepts a message and a
key and outputs some signature.
Verify accepts the
message and the signature
and some other key k2 and
tells us whether or not
it believes that the
message that this m actually
corresponds to this signature.
And we talked about how
if k1 is equal to k2
this is a shared key system.
And if k1 is not equal
to k2 we typically
call this a public key system.
We also talked about our
encrypt and decrypt primitives.
And we said that encrypt accepts
some message m and some key k1
and outputs some
encoded message C.
And decrypt takes C and
some k2 and gives back m.
Again, we have the same
separation between shared key
and public key, private key.
So, if you remember
last time, we
were talking about
this protocol that
was a protocol for establishing
a secure communication channel.
We got as far as talking
about how we would actually
authenticate a user.
We talked about the
process for authentication.
And then we were using
our authentication process
to build up a protocol
for setting up
a secure communication channel.
The way this is going
to work is that we
are going to use a
public key cryptography.
We are going to use our
encryption with a public key
to exchange a shared key.
And then we are going
to use the shared key
to encrypt our communication.
We went through this example
with the Denning-Sacco Protocol
which I will quickly review.
And, remember, I told you
that this protocol is broken.
And we got as far as not quite
figuring out how it was broken.
So let's see if we can
figure out how it was broken.
Again, we said the
idea is Alice first
sends a message to Charles.
And, remember in
our model, Charles
is this certificate authority,
the guy who both Alice
and Bob know and trust.
So Alice sends a message
to Charles saying hey,
I would like to get these
certificates for Alice and Bob
so that I can establish this
clear communication channel.
Charles goes ahead
and agrees with this
and sends a message back
which consists of these two
certificates, one
certificate for Alice
and one certificate for Bob.
Both of these certificates
have been signed
with Charles' private key.
And because they are signed
with Charles' private key
that presumably means that only
Charles could have possibly
generated these certificates.
Okay.
And the contents of these certificates
are simply the public keys of A and B.
There are two certificates,
and each certificate
contains the name of the
principle that the certificate
belongs to, the public
key of that principle
and then some timestamp
which, remember,
we said we want to
use to make sure
that these
certificates are fresh.
And now what happens
is that Alice, in order
to establish this communication
with Bob, needs to exchange
or needs to propose
a shared key that she
can go ahead and use with Bob.
What she does is she
sends her certificate,
which is something
that Bob should
be able to use to validate
that she is, in fact, who
she said she is.
And, remember, she cannot forget
this because it's signed with
Charles' private key.
And she also goes ahead and
sends this proposed key.
And the way she encodes
the proposed key
is to sign it with
her private key
so that Bob knows that it
actually came from her.
And then she encrypts
it with Bob's public key
so that only Bob can actually go
ahead and decode this message.
Let's think for a minute.
We started to get towards
figuring out what's
wrong with this protocol.
And the way that we
started to talk about it
was, well, what properties
would we like a protocol
like this to have?
We said one property
we would like
is for it to have freshness.
What freshness means is that
the protocol shouldn't be
susceptible to replay attacks.
That is somebody shouldn't
be able to overhear a message
and then replay it sometime much
later in order to sort of cause
that message to happen again.
So, even if that person
cannot actually look inside
the contents of the message,
they may be able to get
something to happen simply
by replaying the message.
So freshness is something we
want our protocols to have.
And, in this case, we are
achieving freshness hopefully
by including this T which is
a timestamp in the message.
As I said last time,
getting the timestamp
to actually work
correctly is something
that you have to
be careful about.
And this is described in
Section E of the notes.
The first property is freshness.
The second one is
appropriateness.
That just means that
this message is, in fact,
for the particular
sender, it applies
for the particular sort
of context in which
the message is being used.
So the people who are receiving
the message, for example,
are actually the intended
recipients of the message.
And then the third
property we said
we want is forward secrecy.
And this just means
that it will be
possible to switch to a new
set of keys at some later time
if, for example, the keys
get breached so we have
a way of changing the protocol.
This protocol that we have
also achieves forward secrecy.
The problem it has is
with appropriateness.
Let me show you what I
mean by this protocol being
inappropriate.
Once we've exchanged this
kAB now we can go ahead
and Bob and Alice can presumably
communicate with each other
by encrypting messages to
one another with this kAB key
that they've exchanged.
Let's see what the
problem with this is.
Remember, Alice sends
this message three to Bob.
Now here is what the issue is.
The issue has to do with
this piece of information
that Alice has
encrypted and signed.
And the problem is that this
message does not satisfy
the appropriateness constraint.
In particular, it
doesn't have any context
about which conversation this
key is meant to apply to.
So let me show you a way in
which Bob might exploit this.
Suppose Bob sends a
message to Charles.
And what he sends in this
message is I am Alice
and I would like to set
up a conversation with you
and here is my public key and
here is a bit of information
that I've signed using
my private key that
is a key I would like to
use for our conversation.
So Charles sees this thing and
says oh, yes, Alice signed this
with her private key.
He can check with the
certificate authority
and see that, in
fact, this message
appears to be authentic.
And now he may go ahead
and send a message
back to Bob that is
signed with this kAB.
So Charles has been
fooled into thinking
that Bob is, in fact,
Alice and goes ahead
and starts to establish
some communication with him.
Again, the issue is because
this encrypted and signed thing
doesn't have any information
about what conversation
this key is meant to apply to.
Alice hasn't said
that this is only
a key that applies to a
conversation between Alice
and Bob.
Now, anybody who overhears
this can use this key
to establish a
conversation that appears
to be originating with
Alice that, in fact, is not.
Let me show you how we
go ahead and fix this.
This is just
exactly the protocol
that I showed you before.
And the way that we're
going to fix this
is really pretty much
as I've just described.
We are going to take this
big nasty statement that we
had here, and we're going to
basically sign and encrypt
the whole message instead of
simply signing and encrypting
the one little piece of this
message which was the proposed
key.
We are going to sign and encrypt
the whole thing together,
including Alice's public
key and Alice's certificate.
And we are also going to
include a sender and receiver
in this entire message.
Now we said we
add A and B as two
members of this entire message.
And what this allows
us to do is to guaranty
that because Alice has
signed this entire thing,
Bob isn't able to generate
a new version of this thing,
or Bob isn't able
to use this thing
to spoof a conversation
with Charles.
Bob can go ahead and try and
send this message for Charles,
but Charles could
look at this thing
and obviously tell
that this key was not
for a conversation
between himself
and Alice but instead was for
a conversation between Bob
and Alice.
And there is no
way that Bob could
spoof the generation
of this whole thing
because he doesn't have Alice's
private key so he couldn't
sign this message.
That wraps up most
of our discussion,
the extent of the
discussion from last time.
What we saw last time basically
is a way to do authentication,
and then at the very
end we talk about how
we can use authentication
to establish
the secure
communications channel.
Establishing a secure
communications channel
relies on sort of
the confidentiality
piece of this story,
and I just want
to spend a few minutes talking
about what confidentiality is
and how it works.
Confidentiality, obviously,
is the protection
of information exchange between
two people or two principles,
say Alice and Bob.
And the idea is to make
it so that somebody
who is overhearing
this communication
wouldn't actually
be able to tell
what the contents of the
message that was overheard were.
The idea is suppose Alice
generates some message m,
puts it into an encryption box,
encrypts it with some key k1
and generates a new
message C which gets
sent over the Internet to Bob.
On the other side,
Bob feeds this thing
into a decryption box, decrypts
it with k2 and gets m out.
And this has the properties
that simply knowing C
makes it very hard to derive m.
Given C, deriving m
is very hard to do.
That is because of
the difficulty of sort
of breaking these cryptographic
protocols that we talked about
the first couple times,
but given k2 and C
it is possible to derive m.
The only way that
you can do this
is by applying
some sort of attack
on the cryptographic
mechanism hopefully.
But this property, given
k2 you can derive C,
it is relatively
easy for the receiver
to go ahead and figure
out what the message is.
And since we are using these
encrypt and decrypt boxes,
obviously, k1 could be
equal to k2, in which case
we would be using a
shared key approach.
And k1 and k2 can be
different, in which case
we are using public key
like we talked about.
What we built up in this —
What we did in the secure
communication channel
that we just talked about —
I'll just go over here.
What we did in the secure
communication channel that
I just talked about was to —
was to both authenticate
and establish confidentiality.
—and to authenticate and
then establish confidentiality.
We had both confidentiality
and authentication,
so at the end of this
protocol Alice and Bob
have authenticated
with each other
and they have confidentiality
because they've
exchanged this key
kAB that they can
use to have a private
conversation with one another.
This is going to
be a common thing
that we are going to
want to be able to do,
confidentiality
plus authentication.
And we see the way
that we do that is
exactly the pattern that we have
going on here in this example.
You take a message and you sign
it and then you encrypt it.
So you have your message m.
It is signed with some key
which we will call kconf
for confidentiality.
Sorry.
It is encrypted with kconf.
And then you're going
to sign this whole thing
with some key kauth which is
your key for authorization.
And it is OK, in this case,
for these two things, this sign
and encrypt can be
done in either order.
I can sign the message and
then encrypt it or encrypt it
and then sign it.
It works out just fine.
This pattern is going
to be a common one.
Often times, when
we're building up
a secure system, what you want
to do is first authenticate.
You want to both guaranty that
the person you are talking to,
you want to know who the
person you are talking to is,
and you also want the
communication with that person
to be secure.
We talked at the
beginning, when we first
starting talking
about authentication
we talked about
a simpler example
where you might just
want to authenticate.
I had the example, suppose
you're purchasing something
and you don't care if somebody
knows that you purchase it,
like giving money
to Save the Whales.
That example, you're giving
money to save the whales.
All you care about is that
Save the Whales can actually
authenticate your message,
that the message is
well-formed from
the point of view
that Save the Whales doesn't
believe that you're giving them
$10,000 instead of a $100 and
that Save the Whales knows
who you are so get credit
for giving them that money,
but you don't
actually maybe care
whether that message
is encrypted.
Another common thing
you are going to do
is just sign a
message with kauth.
It is less common to see,
well, the other thing you
might wonder is how
often do people just
want confidentiality?
Just establishing
confidentiality
is sort of less common.
You would see that
less frequently.
Typically, people
want to either do
confidentiality
and authentication
or just authentication.
But just confidentiality is
a little bit of a weird case
because having a private
conversation with somebody
who you don't know there
aren't that many cases where
you want it.
You could imagine an anonymous
communication system,
for example, where
you don't actually
want the other person to know
anything about who you are.
But that's a little bit
of an unusual situation.
These are kind of the two major
forms of private communication
that we have talked
about so far.
And we talked about a
few little other details.
This example illustrated
a few other little details
that we need to make
sure we take care of.
One of them was this
freshness constraint.
In this example, we said
this is e.g., the addition
of T to this example up here.
So, when we add the
timestamps, that
makes it difficult for somebody
to apply a replay attack
against us.
The other thing that we might
want to do is add T to m.
This is freshness.
This is going to
add timestamp to m.
Now, the other
thing we might want
is some way to guaranty
appropriateness.
And, what we're going to do
for appropriateness, what
we need to do to
make sure the message
is appropriate is we need to
add context to the message
so we need to add
some information that
specifies who is originally
involved in the message.
These are sort of the two
major kinds of protection
that we have, and
we need to make sure
that our protocols
we use sort of
provide these kinds
of guarantees.
Now what I want to do is talk a
little bit about authorization.
We've seen authentication
and a bit of confidentiality
and we've talked
about authorization,
but I want to talk about it
in the context of an example.
Because you guys know something
about authorization techniques.
You guys have all seen, for
example, passwords for logging
into a system.
There is no big surprise
about how passwords work.
There is some list of passwords.
And, when a user
tries to log in,
the system checks to see if
the person is in the list.
They typically take the hash of
the password that is typed in
and check to see if the
hash of the password
is in the password list.
This is described in
detail in the text
and we will go over
it a little bit today,
but what I want to do is sort of
talk about how we fit all three
of these things,
authentication, authorization
and confidentiality
together into one system
as we talk about authentication.
We are going to use an example.
Which is the Web.
Suppose that we
were in a situation
where we have some
browser B communicating
with some Web server W over a
secure communication channel.
And, if you like, you can think
of the secure communication
channel as having
been established
by a protocol like the
one I've shown here.
In practice on the Web,
there is a common protocol
that is used to establish the
secure communication channel
called SSL, secure
sockets layer.
This channel has
been authenticated
and is confidential.
It is typically the
case, for example,
that there may be some
certificate authority,
for example, which B has
used to discover keys for W,
to discover a private key to use
to talk to the Web server, W.
There is a question, though,
that we haven't really
got at which is how does W know
that B is authorized to access?
We hinted at this on the
first lecture about security,
but this is the question that
we want to try and address
today in a little more detail.
The issue is that once this
protocol is established,
these two guys have exchanged
a key with each other, this kAB
or kBW.
And this is a shared
key that these guys can
communicate with each other.
But basically all
that W knows about B
is that this is somebody
who has this key.
This is the same B who initiated
this connection with me.
W may not have actually
checked to go ahead and see
what it is on the server, what
services on WB has access to.
So W needs to go
ahead and figure out
what it is that B can access.
And these two sort of
check all the accesses
that B tries to make
on W to make sure
that it is authorized to do so.
If you remember back to
the very first lecture,
we talked about
how authentication
and authorization work.
We sort of said
there are two steps.
Or, in this case, we are
going to actually talk
about three steps.
We have three steps or let's
call it three authorization
functions.
And these functions
actually sort
of share something in
common with authentication
because authenticating
and authorizing
are sort of
intertwined together.
You will see what I mean.
The first step is we
need some rendezvous.
When we talk about
this, this is the way
that two principles initially
set up the access rights
to the particular server.
For example, this is you going
to your system administrator
and telling your
system administrator
that you would like an account.
He creates an account, he
creates a home directly for you
and then you have the rights
to access any of the files that
are in your home directly.
So think of rendezvous as setup.
Account creation, you can
log onto Amazon dot com
and create an
account, for example.
Then there is some
other step which
is this verification step.
And verification is
simply making sure
that when you
reconnect to the system
you are allowed to
connect to the things
that you want to connect to.
Typically, in an
authorization system,
we talk about this thing
mediating your communication
with the Web server.
If I log onto Amazon
dot com and say
that I would like to log
in as a particular user,
this verification step
is going to make sure
that I have the
appropriate credentials
to log on as that user.
The final thing I might
want to do is to revoke.
I might want to simply
remove a user from the system
or make it so that the user is
no longer a part of the system.
There are two widely
sort of used approaches
for authentication that
sort of do different things
at these different steps.
The two approaches are
called lists and tickets.
Authorization.
We have these two approaches.
The first one we are going to
call lists and the second one
is called tickets.
And we have these three steps.
We have our setup step,
we have our mediation step
and we have our revocation step.
Lists are something you
may be familiar with.
One way that we might
authorize whether or not
a user is allowed
to access a system
is to check some list of all the
users who are allowed access,
and we may check that
user's credentials.
For example, if
you go to a party
and that party is
invite only and requires
you to show your MIT ID at the
door, you show up at the door,
you show them your MIT ID
and then that lets you in.
And now you've been sort of
authorized to access the party.
The other approach is a
ticket-based approach.
This is an approach
where instead
of having a list of people
and checking credentials
whenever the person
wants access, instead
you have some ticket
which lets anybody who
has that ticket have access.
This is a party is
invitation only.
You get an invitation
in the mail.
And now anybody who
has that invitation
can go ahead and
go to the party.
You guys are all
familiar with systems
that work like that,
baseball games,
carnival games or
whatever it is.
You get tickets and
you use those tickets
to get access to something.
And anybody who has those
tickets can use them.
There is no checking of your
sort of credentials every time
you try to use them.
As we're going to
see, and we will
talk about how this
works on the Web,
it is often the
case that you use
one of these list-based
authentication systems
to decide who we should
issue tickets to.
And then you give a
bunch of people tickets
and anybody can do whatever
they want with those tickets.
Let's talk about sort of the
properties of these things
and a little bit
about how they work
in the context of
a computer system.
The setup process
and list is obviously
you add someone to a list.
Passwords typically are done
with list-based systems.
The idea is when you add
somebody to a password list
you input their name
or their account name
and a cryptographic hash of the
password that they typed in.
Usually, you want them
to type the password in,
in some secure fashion.
You put the cryptographic
hash of that password there.
And then, in order to mediate,
in order to actually verify,
for example, that the password
is going to be correct,
you are going to
search the list and you
are going to verify that the
password that they present,
in fact, hashes to the stored
hash in the password file.
You are going to search
the list and you're
going to also do this sort
of check credentials step
and make sure the password is
what it was supposed to be.
It is relatively easy
then, in this environment,
to revoke somebody's access.
You can remove them from list.
And then, in that
case, well, they
won't be able to use
the system anymore.
Tickets.
The idea in a
ticket-based system
is that you are going
to generate a ticket.
And usually what that
means in a computer system,
or the simplest way to generate
a ticket in a computer system
is to make a sort of
hard to guess number.
For example, this might
be a hash of something
or it might just be
a big random number.
You want it to be something
that if somebody picks
another random number
out of thin air
they don't have a very high
probability of guessing
a number that actually allows
them to access the system,
but anybody who has
this ticket should
be able to access the
system relatively easily.
Because these tickets
are just, for example,
a big random number,
users typically
should feel free to
share these, might
be able to exchange these
tickets with each other.
They should be able to
share them with other people
and use them for access.
Whereas, users typically are not
going to share their passwords
with other people.
Tickets are a way that
a user can handoff
sort of the authority,
the right to access
a system to some other
user, they can delegate.
Now, to mediate we are
just going to look up,
this is just going
to be a table lookup.
We just need to make sure that
this is a valid number that
was, in fact, given to us.
And, typically, we don't have
to go and check credentials.
The user doesn't have to supply
a password when they supply us
with a ticket.
And then, finally,
in order to revoke,
well, we might be able
to invalidate a ticket.
You might be able to say,
for example, remove her
from the table.
That works fine if we're
OK with getting rid
of an entire ticket.
But suppose, for
example, that I want
to revoke the right of a single
user to access the system.
That is very hard to do
in a ticket-based system.
Suppose that you guys decide
that you no longer want
me looking at some
discussion board about 6.033
that you've set up.
And suppose because you're
writing bad things about me
and you say, well, we
don't want the professor
to be able to
access this anymore.
So you try and revoke my access.
If you've been using
a ticket-based system
that is going to be
very hard unless you
invalidate that ticket.
And there are many people who
are sharing the same ticket.
That's going to be
hard to deny me access
because you're going to
have to revoke that ticket
and then go to
everybody else who might
be sharing that ticket
and issue them a new one.
Whereas, in this sort
of list-based system
you could have just
removed my account.
This has an analogy
in the real world.
For example, door locks are sort
of like a ticket-based system.
You generate a physical
key for something.
You could give that
out to many people,
and then many people can
have access to your house.
The problem is if you
want to revoke access
to a single person then you
have to sort of go and either
collect the keys from everybody,
which may not be feasible,
or change the door locks
which denies everybody
access until you reissue keys
to the people who need them.
If you like, you can think
of a ticket-based system
sort of like being
door locks in a house.
Oftentimes lists are
more formally called
ACLs or access control lists.
You will see this term used
in the text, in fact, as well.
And tickets are sometimes
called capabilities.
Capabilities are
sort of the right
to access some resource
on the computer that
can be delegated from one user
to the other or one principle
to the other.
And, in practice, what
we see both, as I said,
in the real world and
in computer systems
is that we are
often going to use
this list-based mechanisms to
decide who to hand tickets out
to.
In the case of, OK,
who are we going
to invite to our
party, who are we
going to send invitations
to in the mail,
well, you might have some
list that you go ahead
and assemble based
on either people
who you know to be MIT
students or people who
meet some particular set
of eligibility criteria.
That is the sort of
process of checking a list.
And then, once you've
assembled the list,
you are going to generate these
tickets and send them out,
and then anybody can
use those tickets.
This same analogy sort of
holds true in the Internet,
so let's look at how we might
build up an authorization
system on top of our secure
channel between our browser
and our Web server.
We have our B talking over
our secure channel of our Web
server.
And the idea is going
to be as follows.
This Web server has some
service that the user wants
to try and access, and we
are going to have this guard.
Remember, we talked about
this guard model before.
There is going to
be some guard that
sits in front of
this service that
is in charge of authorizing
B to access this service.
And then there is some
authorization module
that runs on B.
The idea is that B is going
to initiate a connection
and then guard is going to send
a message to the authorization
module on B saying who are
you, what are your credentials
to access this system?
This is going to be a
form of list-based access.
Now, this module on B is
going to go ahead and send
a message back that says my
name is, whatever my name is,
as well as some key, some
credential like, for example,
a password that is their
password for accessing
this system.
Notice that these
two guys do not
need to worry about sort of
protecting this channel, as
far as the rest of the
Internet is already concerned,
because they have already
established this secure channel
upon which they can do this
exchange of information.
So they are hopefully not
worried about other people
overhearing this message.
They may not need to protect
this information that
is being transmitted
in the same way
because they have already
got the secure communication
channel that they have
established at the lower
levels of this thing.
All of this
communication is going
over this secure communication
channel between these two guys.
This is a layer
that is built on top
of this secure
communication layer.
Now what happens is that
what the guard is going to do
is look up this name and
password, for example,
in some access
control list and use
that to determine whether
or not this person has
the rights to
access and what they
have the rights to access to.
And he is going to
generate for this person
a set of tickets that
represent the sort of services
that this person can
access on this system.
He is going to have
some table of tickets,
and this table is going
to have the ticket
number and the resource, for
example, that the user is
allowed to access.
So he is going to send back
some ticket number authNo back
to the user.
So we are going to add authNo.
And then maybe this
gives him the right
to access some account,
B's account information.
Now, with this
authorization information,
this is the ticket.
Now every time that B wants
to go ahead and access
his account, for example,
he can read account B
and then he just
passes the ticket.
And he can use this
ticket over and over
and over again to access
the account for as long
as the ticket is valid.
Often times there
will be a timeout
associated with tickets.
But as long as the
ticket is valid
he can go ahead and supply
this ticket in order
to be able to access the
resource that the ticket gives
him access to.
And he doesn't have to sort
of re-authenticate himself.
He doesn't have to represent
his credentials every time
he wants to access this resource
on his account on the Web
server.
Are the HKN people here?
Yes.
OK.
We need to do HKN.
Why don't you just give me one
more minute to wrap up and then
we can go ahead and
do the HKN review.
On the Internet this works.
This protocol, I mentioned
that this is sort of like SSL,
or the SSL works in
sort of this way.
On the Internet you may
have heard about cookies.
Cookies on the Web are
essentially a kind of ticket.
The idea with most
cookie-based systems
is you log in with a password.
And then, when you log
in with that password,
the system issues you a cookie.
And then when you want
to re-access the system
you simply supply the cookie.
If you were to look
at the contents
of a prototypical cookie,
it would typically
have something
like, for example,
the user's name
and some timeout,
a valid period for
the cookie, as well as
a hash of the user's name,
that timeout and some,
for example, random number
which is only known over here
at the service.
The service is going to
protect this random number
and is going to hash it
together with the user's
ID and this timeout.
And so now, when this
cookie is supplied,
it is going to be hard for
users to generate fake cookies,
but these cookies are
going to allow the user
to go ahead and access the
services on W without having
to re-authenticate every time.
And you can, in fact,
in some cookie systems
share those cookies.
You could copy the cookie
from one browser to another,
and you might be able
to reuse that cookie
to access the system for as
long as the cookie is valid.
Cookies typically timeout
after an hour or two,
and so then you would
have to re-authenticate
with the system.
That is all I wanted to really
say about authentication.
What we are going to do
is talk about some sort
of advanced protocols next time.
I want to remind
you guys that there
is no class on this
Wednesday so don't come here.
The next class is next Monday.
And that is it.
Good luck finishing your DP2
and have fun doing HKN reviews.